[Musique]
qui connaît pas gaou tombent de la table
quand il connaît bien le benjamin
oui bon on a vu on a vu enfin je connais
oui recevront les marseillais de manière
à s'éloigner mais ça fait quand même
plusieurs années qu'il est là donc
évidemment qu'on le connaissait les
personnages phares des marseillais vous
faites les mares 5 en septembre
50 m les marseillais c'est quoi les
critères pour être sélectionné dans les
marseillais un mois c'est pour moi
c'était valoir seuil et marseillais bien
évidemment mais c'est un peu du hasard
pour moi ah oui c'est vrai que moi j'ai
passé le casting à la dernière minute
j'ai un peu fait rigoler la productrice
et on m'a dit mme parcours vas-y pas
garde par à miami en tant que dj j'étais
là je vous êtes dj alors vous voulez
faire quoi en fait dit j'ai un peu tout
moi la vérité bagages
comment pouvez vous êtes payé pour une
saison des marseillais à peu près comme
toi mais tu divises par un million
[Rires]
normalement vous êtes payés en quoi
cette île et 12000 euros selon
l'ancienneté de votre participation
meilleurs qu'on a produit cette nuit
l'euro ou du vélo pour toute la saison
la productrice a aurait indiqué a bien
indiqué cdg chiffre entre 7000 et 12000
euros pour toute la saison ça dure comme
une saison ça fait cinq saisons que je
fais enfin cinq ans donc j'ai fait à peu
près 10 16 ans ouais bon j'arrive
toujours en cours où je pars avant donc
d'accord plus ou moins on va dire que ça
fait comment ça le prit alors le prix à
la fourchette
tout dépend en fait tout dépend si on
est bien sur les moyens de bord et vous
vous êtes bon dos on peut apporter
vous vous êtes bon et moi je suis aux
alentours de 500 mille euros par part
non sérieusement c'est dans ces critères
là bravo bravo à brommat dire j'ai pas
envie de parler aux actionnaires d'accor
voilà on va venir ce qui s'y passe à la
télé et on va revenir vers sur dans un
instant sur ce qui a marqué les
marseillais c'est cette histoire avec
votre votre compagne on va arriver on va
y revenir vous allez voir gernez même
lui ne va pas être bien du tout je vous
le dis